let's talk now briefly about dr anthony
fauci
dr fauci has finally had enough and is
now straight up saying
the trump campaign is harassing me and
hell no i'm not going to quit my job
remember that dr fauci is the top
infectious disease doctor in the u.s
he's been increasingly sidelined and
ignored by the trump campaign
he was pulled out of the public eye
after being in it early in the pandemic
he was blocked from doing tv interviews
by the trump administration
and what looks to be the last straw for
him is that he was taken out of context
and used in a trump campaign ad
in a way that sort of makes it look like
fouchy is endorsing trump when it was
actually completely out of context
fauci asked about this while on cnn over
the weekend take a look
i i do have to ask you about this trump
campaign advertisement where you're on
camera saying quote i can't imagine
that anybody could be doing more you
quickly came out with a statement that
noted
that that sentence had been taken out of
context you were talking about
the whole of government response not
president trump and of course you've
never endorsed a presidential candidate
in your five decades
of public service should the trump
campaign take this ad down
you know i think so jake i think it's
really unfortunate
and really disappointing that they did
that it's so clear that i'm not a
political person
and i have never either directly or
indirectly
endorsed the political candidate and to
take a completely out of contact
statement and put it in which is
obviously a political campaign and i i
thought was really very disappointing
what would you say if i told you i heard
that the trump campaign was actually
preparing to do another ad featuring you
you know that would be terrible i mean
that would be outrageous if they do that
um
in fact that might actually come back to
backfire on them i
i hope they don't do that because that's
that would be kind of playing a game
that we don't want to play so i hope
they reconsider that
if in fact they are indeed considering
doing that
i hope that they reconsider and not do
that that
mention of it might backfire is
something that has raised questions as
to whether fauci is threatening to quit
when fauci says this might backfire
there were questions are you threatening
to quit and he has said very clearly
he is not threatening to quit after that
interview fauci was interviewed by the
daily beast
and asked if he's considering quitting
he said not a chance
not in my wildest freaking dreams
did i ever think about quitting but he
did go on to say
that quote by doing this against my will
they are in effect harassing me
look at how backwards this country is dr
fauci who is trying to save people and
keep people alive
ended up needing full-time security
thanks to harassment from trumpists dr
fauci's family
including his daughters required
security because
they were being threatened and fauci is
a public health expert
he's being forced to babysit a toddler
instead of save lives
and to defend his family from attacks
with security
how can we be forgiven for this
constantly scapegoated
taken out of context denounced ignored
and pushed aside now for months and all
because in his narcissistic mind
donald trump thinks he's the only one
who can fix things and
unfortunately many of trump's
sycophantic followers agree when trump
said well you know scientists
i know more than the scientists many of
his followers cheered that they went
right along with it and one of the
things i most look forward to about joe
biden winning if he wins
is dr fauci being treated the way he
deserves to be treated
coming back to the forefront of speaking
to the country
in an official capacity about how to
manage the pandemic
it would be nice to see fauci allowed to
do
what he should be doing what others in
fauci's position in other countries are
being allowed to do
and you know these taking fouchy out of
context for a campaign
ad is the the lowest of the low
and it quite frankly isn't working
remember that
dr fauci is far more trusted
than trump on the virus they've been
trying to smear fouchy for months
and i guess you could say well the the
delta between
trump's trustworthiness on the virus and
fouches might be even bigger were it not
for the smear campaign
but the last numbers we have from from
last month
68 percent of americans say they trust
fauci
on the virus 40 say they trust trump
now that's depressing because how how
the hell
does 40 of the country trust trump on
the virus
but at least fouchy's trustworthiness is
almost twice what trump's is
but something is very wrong here when
trump says i know more than scientists
and people cheer
and 40 percent of the country still
trusts
trump on the virus we'll have more
coverage
of the out-of-context use of fouchy
video
by the trump campaign on the show's
instagram page
make sure you're following us there at
david pakman show